As you can see, developers get really
excited about Salesforce. And we're really excited to
teach this course. I started working at Salesforce
six years ago. And while I was initially
excited to be working for the undisputed leader
in cloud computing, what really got me excited
was working on the platform, and the limitless
possibilities of what you can build on Salesforce.
>> And I don't work at Sales Force. I work
Udacity, because I like teaching people things. Things that will
help them improve their life. And I think if you learn
Salesforce, you actually can get a job, and that's pretty cool.
>> When I started working at Salesforce,
three years ago, what really intrigued me about
the platform was just how easy it was to build apps on it. you have
a lot of free range as a developer to build whatever you want with code.
You can do so much with just
point and click. It's a really interesting platform.